The joe rogan experience,
me and Brian,
this is like a,
we're almost at our sixth anniversary right now.
This is our 600 versus,
I'm pretty sure it was,
it was totally this month,
but whenever it was,
it was definitely this month,
six years ago.
It's just fucking around on Ustream.
Just,
uh,
answering questions,
you know,
pre hib days.
I,
I mean,
I've banged a swinger,
uh,
in front of his wife,
Oh,
sorry,
in front of,
in front of him,
in front of him.
That dude,
I bang the wife,
the husband was watching,
why would you want that?
And I'm like,
right,
as long as we're,
nobody's fucking touching me,
I'm good at just as long as it's just women on me,
I'm good.
And this has got beaten off or anything.
The husbands and the corn just stroking it.
When I was in la,
I moved a couple times.
I moved to Sierra Benita here in West Hollywood and I moved into this shitty
building and the guy goes,
and this is before anybody who knew Mitch was,
or he goes,
you're a comedian.
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
well,
this is a standup comedian.
He lives right next to you.
And I go,
what's his name?
He goes,
I don't know,
Mitch something,
no,
whatever.
And I'm like,
I know it.
Never fucking heard of him.
And then you know about,
I'd say a month and a half later,
two months later I'm watching TV.
I was on the road somewhere and he and my neighbors on the,
on Letterman.
And I go,
this guy's is funny as anybody I've ever fucking heard of my life.
Scott lives next to me.
And then he did a joke about me cause I used to bang on his wall,
play guitar or his wife or his girlfriend did.
They used to have me sing alongs and shit,
not bang on the wall.
I could shut the fuck up.
And uh,
and I'm in shock crop.
Yeah.
And uh,
so Zoe from the Improv,
so yeah,
she was in New York one night.
She goes,
she was there to help Mitch put his,
let him and said,
she goes,
you know,
he has a bit,
it says Depaulo on the Napkin that says Depalo on the Napkin.
And that's the bit of make banging on the wall and he goes,
there's no doorknob.
Come around at some,
but something about the door opening and a wall.
That's it.
It's up.
All right.
This is the first ever HD version of this podcast.
Brian.
Stan,
you are the guest.
Wow.
Damn it.
You're the perfect guy for this first ever first ever.
You stream HD version of the podcast you want,
I'll send you a copy of the 45 spot I get.
I mean you said that you don't date.
I just,
I've never said there'll be a date I refuse.
Especially if people from La that would call me up again.
We'll putting together a TV show with you that they love the 50th accomplished
though.
They'll be,
yeah,
I don't fucking send the tapes.
Mark Babbitt.
I sent them a blank tape.
Okay.
You're earning your keep.
That's one thing I'd rather know where I stand and get fucked with.
That's the leg I'm talking about.
Really?
You need a tape of me.
You just saw him at the store.
What the fuck do you leave?
If I'm good enough for Mitzi shore.
Why do you want to tape?
Who the fuck are you and your fucking shit down to want to take from me?
I'm not the fucking major league.
Oh,
fucking comedy.
The comedy store.
You call me.
You want a date?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm not sending you a fucking day.
It's against my fucking will.
I called like three or four girls or girls.
Hey,
I think I've herpes.
Uh,
uh,
you should,
you should go get tested and stop fucking dammit.
Like why am I,
I have a outbreak.
I have a herpes out.
There's no way there's anything else.
I have a herpes outbreak.
Yeah.
Cause what else could it be?
You just don't wake up and have a scab.
Exactly.
And then while I was hanging out,
I was hanging out the stand.
How many club?
Maybe the best club in New York.
But I'm talking to the owner and Pete Lee,
this comedian and tell them my problem.
And Pete was like,
where is it?
Like right underneath the hood of Your Dick?
And I'm like,
yeah,
right there.
He's like,
I had something like this once.
It was like a penile tear.
Have you done anything like rough lately?
And I was like,
yeah,
actually I noticed it right after unlubricated anal sex.
That's when I first noticed it,
but it just didn't go away.
And lucky you're alive.
I'm lucky I'm alive.
And then I,
that's what it turned out to be.
How do you have unlubricated anal sex?
That's like fucking hard bro.
I worked with a Rickles this summer.
Oh,
so great.
My whole objective those two days was I just want to be shit on by him.
I just watch.
I was just lobbing stuff and I'm like done.
So,
uh,
we were working together two nights,
so like,
you know,
I have to that we're going to know each other pretty well.
You think when we get back to la,
we're going to hang out.
Well,
don't push it.
Yeah.
You know,
and then I'm like waiting for him.
Right.
Just totally that I liked done.
Uh,
are you gonna Watch my act tonight?
I really appreciate it.
If you watch my act,
I am a little busy
and I get very involved.
I get involved in politics in Britain,
but not party politics.
But this lobbying for this,
spend money on the young,
spend money on the education system,
spend money on inspiration.
Make sure that there's a generation of these great engineers and scientists that
the America is currently,
we're leading in.
Absolutely.
Um,
and make sure that they're still there.
It makes you,
and how do you get them?
How do you inspire them?
I don't want kids to one and be a singer is actually particularly annex fact.
It's there.
I don't want them to be famous.
There's a survey done recently,
I think,
where they said to low skilled kids,
what'd you want to be when you grow up?
And,
and,
and a lot of them said,
famous.
Famous.
What do you mean famous?
You want to walk on the moon?
Don't you want to,
do you want to invent the world's fastest computer?
Don't you do one then?
What'd you mean famous?
You've got to be famous for something.
So what are you or make you think wearables is on the verge of extinction?
There's articles written about it.
Oh,
the instances of genital crabs have drastically reduced since the implementation
of pornographic,
visual,
vagina trimming and penis trimming.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
because people would shave their pussies and does not me not you let it wild.
Yeah.
100% man has got a afro pick in it,
but then the tires will come into the change room and instead looking at,
they'll come and feel your arms like a horse.
See how fit you are.
Look you up and down like you're just a piece of meat.
Should I put money on him?
Yeah,
sure.
It looks pretty good or it looks a bit flabby.
Nah,
Nah.
But on the other guy.
So we'll just check you out and talk and to come and fill you and every touch
you touch your belly to see if you have a strong stomach.
These are just gamblers,
gamblers,
and then fucking weird.
And then at them,
the change rooms next to the Thai toilets as well.
So as they're coming in for a piece,
they might come out and fill your ass white.
So kind of [inaudible] you got pretty much pretty bizarre.
So a lightning bet is you assign a number,
an amount of money to each point that the bat goes over or under,
which means if you lightening bet $1,000 on an over at one 80 once you hit the
over,
I get the chills saying,
once you hit the over every single basket that gets hit in the game,
you win $1,000 every from both teams.
Both teams on a basket from the field is to grant a three pointers,
three grams every single bed housing.
So like the shakes you start to get while you're watching her,
literally like they're,
they're visible.
It's almost like,
you know,
you're having a connection and you have drank,
maybe coax calm you down and every time a shot goes up it's like,
eh.
And to me it's the purest form of degenerate gambling I've ever seen.
I brought you something.
Oh,
those yours.
Do you recognize those reading glasses?
Do you recognize those?
No,
I don't.
Sure.
Yes,
I think you left those bitches at my house and like 2009 uh,
I think Lisa Loeb left these at your house or your housing and nine,
they might be confused.
Sure.
I'm,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Thanks brother.
Thanks for getting that same routes.
Adam is gentleman in a long running tradition of people leaving shit behind the
podcast.
Adam Corolla has left behind his glasses.
Oh my goodness.
I don't want to have your fucking glasses.
It'll talk to you
when you're surviving.
Getting teachers spirit,
animal food in plastic and then eat it and then poop it out and eat it later.
Like I'm take the plastic off and eat it.
Jesus Christ.
It seems like it could work.
That's a technique I've never thought.
I mean,
if you're going to be like on your own for five days,
you can eat a bunch of food,
but wrap it up in plastic and then later poop it out then and take it out with
them.
How would you get the nutrients from the food in the first place?
When we go to your stomach in a piece of plot?
What is this?
Poop it out and understand and then you poop it out like before you leave for
your trip,
go to go get stuffed like a loss of market or something
where you're poorly thought out ideas and they get a bunch of plastic.
Don't tell him stop.
Can't,
can't tell guy to eat as poop.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying like eat like a big meal before you're about to leave and he would
eat his own food.
It's called the youth.
It's called second harvest and then native Americans and maybe take a bunch of
like protein bars,
wrap them up in plastic,
eat it and then poop it out in a couple of days and then unwrap the plastic they
need.
What kind of Shit?
Really think a fucking whole protein bar in plastic can make it through your
digestive track.
Carry the bars in my backpack and just eat him three days later.
Porous understanding of the human digestive tract ever exhibited on a podcast.
I was trying to figure out what you were saying.
I thought you were saying eating poop.
You're not talking about a little Baggie of heroin that a drug mule swallow.
I was thinking like,
maybe we're going to make you survive.
You'll,
you'll get another hour's worth of energy from that little heroin bag.
What about petite filets and
he hated ounces wrapped in plastic.
You're going to die.
How long has uncle Paul been around for?
Well,
he started,
uncle Paul started is,
I've been doing calculus for years and relationships long before I did them on
the radio.
I didn't to I my girlfriends,
he was uncle Larry many years ago.
There was Roger Davis or Roger [inaudible] and uh,
this is long before chip that was Roger and Roger had a brother Lester,
who was burned in a fire and unless was,
you've got a whole time,
like all storyline.
Lester was burned everywhere,
but his knees and his,
until he would always wear knickers to show off his legs was a whole thing.
And Uncle Roger,
I know uncle,
uncle Larry and then emerged into chip who my girlfriend hated so much.
Chip became the fucking cause they would chip,
would embarrass people.
I did had literally before I ever thought I'd do on the radio,
I would be out with girlfriends and embarrass them by doing that.
Like we,
I'll just be making bad jokes in the cab and my girlfriend and I,
you know a a gen and even grow up go home.
We just go shut the fuck up.
It's not funny and it made me so happy and like this is what we're drive Jenny
crazy.
He'd be like a really nice steakhouse and the way they would come over and she
would order like the salmon and then chip just goes,
how much is that?
I would ask the way there and she was like,
do you know how humiliating it is that people think I fucked that guy?
He puts think I'm fucking this guy
first.
I'm going to talk about the so called philosophical issue of how long would we
want to live.
I find that quite remarkable that people worry about this simply because it's
not the way that people actually think about anything else.
When people ask me they things off sometimes say,
okay,
take yourself back to the first time you got light.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Now think about what you were thinking at the time.
What are you thinking?
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
I have to get this person into bed right now because I've only got another 60
years to live.
So what?
I mean it's just ridiculous.
The difference between
the feeling you get when you hear,
oh it was brain damage.
I sort of have that feeling about everything.
You know,
if you,
if,
if we,
if he gets a brain scan,
if he goes to trial now he gets a brain scan and we,
and we find that his brain is just massively damaged and all the right areas
that would have eroded his impulse control.
Right.
That would seem to let him off the hook a little bit.
Which he would,
he would look like someone who is unlucky more than he would look like a bad
person.
Right.
And I sort of see bad people as unlucky to,
I recognize that there's certain people who are quite classically bad people.
There are psychopaths who you just,
not only can you not rely on them,
you,
you can rely on them to be bad actors,
you know,
so you,
you,
you have to,
you have to be in a posture of,
of self defense with respect to these people.
But um,
I do view them as an unlucky on some fundamental level
and hair was more of like an eyelash for the vagina,
for periods and stuff.
So when and get everywhere and that's why girls are,
that's not what it is.
The uh,
the butthole hair was always disturbing though.
Yeah.
I don't like nobody ever liked the buddle here cause some gals just did not know
what they're doing when Kim to wiping.
And back then nobody had a bad day and nobody had baby wipes.
It was toilet paper sometimes.
Some of it stuck around.
I said joints for a little GI.
Joe
[inaudible] super tightly rolled up.
This is hilarious.
Boy,
this is so bizarre.
Watching.
Hey,
get out of there.
So we're watching Kevin Pereira and it's the attack on,
on twitch.
We'll get it gone.
I see your hearing loss looks,
Bro.
Fuck today.
Back with that.
Let's bring it out.
Wow.
This is very strange
studio Joe.
Just wait.
I'm going to give you the
now.
This is interesting.
[inaudible] it's freaking me out now we've got the
bar
watching US watching them.
This is fucking rain.
I think we can time travel somehow.
I think we just did.
Look what we're doing.
We're showing his dick again.
Joe's got a full head of hair.
What's good?
Cause he's all so bizarre.
It's like a mailbox or whatever.
That movie was my voice.
She's got deeper.
Just ginger's trying too hard,
right?
Marianne's got a straw hat on Marianne is she's the girl in the barn given out
handjobs no,
no,
no.
You marry your bro.
What the fuck?
No,
you married Mrs Howl.
Okay.
You gotta bring her a lot of jewelry,
but you married her look.
Oh,
look at you.
Look at Maryanne's body in that.
Holy Shit.
She had that seventies body to a little wider in the hips.
A little thick at the top of the leg,
but the flat ass
belly with the recess belly button.
Oh my God.
Any shots of the feet.
Joe Walsh is first of all,
an absolute king.
Like,
let me tell you,
he's one of the nicest guys I've ever opened for a,
he's like so cool.
You'd think it'd be Joe was like,
Hey,
I'm in the eagles.
Who the fuck are those?
It wasn't like that at all,
but we're eating a a deli tray and he comes into the dressing room and he says,
Hey,
uh,
don't eat that shit.
And we're like,
well,
why?
And he goes,
ah,
you,
you don't know what's in there man.
You know,
it was just a Shitty Deli tray.
Don't eat it.
He's all,
I got sick before.
And I was like,
oh,
really?
And he goes,
yeah,
let me tell you.
He goes,
after he was out of the eagles,
he had a real low spot where he is partying hard and cancel on gigs all the
time.
So he cleaned up and uh,
the manager said,
we're book a tour,
but if you cancel one show,
all the shows will be gone.
So the first night of the tour,
he's backstage eaten on the Deli tray after sound check.
And about a couple of hours later he gets mad food poisoning and he starts just
shitting and shitting and he's like,
what am I,
I got to cancel.
And the manager goes,
you cancel this Gig.
The entire tour is gone.
So they go to Kmart or whatever was open and they get the rubber fishing waders.
He puts him on the ones that go up to your tits.
They were like,
we river runs through it,
fly fishing.
He gets on stage and just going at it,
why are you shitting?
Like every couple,
like every few minutes.
Oh,
oh,
you're
shitting into rubber winning
Joe.
He didn't expect this.
But the heat from the lamp started burning the diary
acids on his legs
and no one looked at Joe Walsh awareness cause he wore weird shit all the time.
He showed tonight
shitting himself with just sometimes mean regular fresh say.
Oh.
Sounded like last night I thought yesterday.
I,
you know,
when you stay away from seafood for awhile and then reintroduce it,
there's bacteria in like,
you know,
it's different since shellfish and Sushi.
And I,
I,
I thought when,
I guess when I farted,
it sounded like somebody was throwing up like the front sounded like a guy
going,
you know,
I,
I've only shaved my ass once in my life,
but once I did,
oh my God,
my farts sounded so different.
Really?
Oh,
they were all like wet and sloppy.
It's a hair kind of different.
The hair on your ass literally changes the way your farts smell or sound rather.
Right.
Smell this smell the same,
but they sound different.
Plop,
plop,
plop.
Somebody tells me king her but doesn't shave.
That's a whole new area he'd get into.
That's a whole monster.
That guy dating that guy.
He doesn't have a girlfriend or girlfriend.
He scrapes up his youtube,
like add video money.
Then then he gets a hooker farts on her.
Like,
no,
I hate it.
You fucking loser
my videos of,
no you don't.
And then you come out of it and you slowly come out of it and you were like,
noise canceling headphones.
I'm just at a doctor's office,
like in a weird,
not even weird,
like those like 1970s doctors' offices that you see in la,
like just sort of a shitty elevator and whatever.
Um,
so when I came out of the first one,
I was like,
it was rough because hey,
I didn't know it was going a trip like that.
And B,
I had been,
I didn't get a ton of sleep the night before and uh,
so I was,
and I'd flown that day.
It was just kind of groggy and uh,
and I felt really shitty and it took me like,
I was like,
after I was done,
I probably laid in the bed there for like an hour.
So it was like,
I can't do shit right now.
Like I can't,
I could barely stand.
So the first it was rough and,
uh,
and that,
and I still felt shitty that night and I was like,
I don't think I'm going to do it again.
Like that was too rough.
And,
um,
then I woke up Tuesday morning and felt fucking great.
I was like,
oh,
um,
I got to do it again.
666 podcasts dunk and he could do whatever you want.
It can be only one for the 666 podcasts to be you,
Jim,
or have a grill you dated.
Kill herself.
No,
they should have.
I put that fucking helmet Grad Committee.
You fucking Dick
to yourself the first time and when you get to your destination,
I'll say Karen.
Yeah,
she was cool.
Smart.
Oh,
she cool.
Shoot.
When you went like this.
She was,
she's all right.
Smart Guy.
I wouldn't go with fucking great.
Great's intense.
Great.
Might be a little intense and too much of a big word.
It'd be a little hyperbole there may never seen one of her parents about that.
Fuck.
I swear to God,
I have never seen her not wanting,
never seen her work.
Not all.
How dare you not do research for that episode.
Yeah.
Well,
I know she's,
I went,
yeah,
she does some heavy shit to almost too much where you go,
okay,
well that can't be,
well I,
my podcast,
she said,
uh,
her skin was bad because she was taking in her van and Tom said,
I,
you're taking in too much testosterone.
Too many loads.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You got a whore on your hands for testing cure.
Imagine if you'd taken somebody loads and it changes your biological profile.
You imagine if you're just dating a girl,
shut down my fucking face.
Keeps breaking out.
What's happening?
These fucking guys busting all over my face,
man in her.
Oh,
you're in Jeff.
So much come in her body.
Yeah,
probably annually.
A lot of it and go,
ah,
it doesn't make that noise when I'm coming,
unless I'm fine.
Yeah,
I've never had that noise cause something hot about that.
There's something hot about that though.
I would agree with you with asa.
I agree.
I like a turbo slot and so I always have always will do to like contact asa and
have her print up that shirt
with glitter.
I'll bake you a shirt.
Asa Hashtag [inaudible] why don't we make them all wear turbans.
Talked to mark it my map too.
No,
it's not.
I met a,
I met a woman at one of my shows in Brooklyn.
She had no hands or feet.
What happened to her?
Well,
she came up to me after the show and she like wanted to like give me a hug.
She was like,
you're so funny.
And she had like these stubs and she said,
you remind me of the girls who did my nails when I had hands.
And I was like,
whoa.
Then like I said so much to tape,
it was like racism,
Korea,
Vietnam,
what the fuck?
Oh,
I was like,
I was thinking like I want to bring it up if I just met her any other way.
Right.
But since she brought up her hand,
I was like,
what happened to your hands?
And she said that she had,
um,
something wrong with her appendix went to the hospital and the doctor put the
wrong name,
like mixed up her charts and they amputated her hands and her feet
when she was only supposed to get her appendix taken out or something.
Very minor.
What?
Yeah,
like I did,
uh,
my friend Sam Cedars,
a podcast a couple of weeks back and,
and he said,
I don't want to give away with the movies.
I said,
listen man,
it's not that kind of movie in a hinges largely on the fact that I survived
rapes as a child.
Well,
I got,
I heard from several people said,
you know,
you really should have had a trigger warning on there.
And it's like,
what the fuck do you shake?
I was doing,
what the fuck do you think I was doing when I said it hinges largely I was
warning you that what it was about right there.
But someone has empowered you to,
to have a way to take issue with me because
I'm not completely basing.
I like,
you know,
the whole world isn't based around me.
Even though I got raped when I was four years old.
Everybody shouldn't be thinking in terms of that all the time because they'd
been through their own shit and they're dealing with their own shit and they're
trying to survive.
So if I can make them more sensitive to this issue,
if I can show them that it matters to them,
the,
that they deal with other people who have been through this kind of trauma and
we want to reduce it as much as absolutely possible,
that's good.
But after that,
if I'm going to find a way to set up a situation where I'm always the injured
party and that prove again and again that I'm persecuted and no one's thinking
in terms of me,
then I'm never going to get fucking hailed.
I'm never going to get fucking healed.
So one I did was I went out and I try to help other people.
When I help other people,
I realized how far along I've come and I realized there's really something in it
for me to do that.
And it's not like I'm this altruistic guy.
It's like I'm saving my own life.
And you know,
looked at AOL investigation that took such courage to do it.
No.
What would have taken courage was turning my back on those kids and walking away
going like,
Ooh,
I don't want to know what's going on in there.
I,
how would I live with that guy?
How would I live with myself then?
But they,
you know,
like I,
it was nice.
Everyone said,
Oh gee,
that what he went through when he was doing that investigation.
What about the kids in the fucking pictures?
That's what I want everyone to know about.
Thanks for caring about me.
But it's the kids in the pictures I give a shit about.
It's the kids that are suffering right now somewhere within the Sada,
my voice,
someone you know,
I mean in this broadcast,
like where this is on someone in the next apartment or wherever some kid is
going through this shit,
have the courage to know about it.
That's all I asked.
You have the courage to know about it and save the contemporary children so you
don't have to deal with a much a fucking maniac.
Abuse survivors went up.
That's all.
And if anybody can diffuse the arounds Cape guys coming in now,
not everybody agrees.
I don't,
I don't know anybody who doesn't think that these shootings,
police shootings are horrific,
but to to interrupt a guy who is easily the most liberal.
That's what was going to say is that of all the candidates for president,
a guy who is the most diverse and guy who march with Martin Luther fucking king.
Yeah,
he marched in the civil rights movement.
He's been a civil rights advocate since the 1960s and they interrupt his
presidential speeches.
You don't have a theory that a lot of these,
a lot of these folks,
the Che Avera wearing tee shirt wearing guys,
they want to feel part of a greater cause.
Yes.
So even though many of those battles have passed them by they,
they'd been one,
I mean rights,
civil rights.
I mean,
of course there's still racism,
but in terms of institutionalized and then a criticism,
we certainly are much better than we were 50 years ago.
But yet,
you know,
they're young kids,
they revolutionary,
they're wearing Che Guevara,
you know,
Viva La Revolution and they have to engage in this kind of behavior.
30 years from now,
they'll watch that youtube clip and they'll think they're a bunch of buffoons.
Well,
I think anytime you,
you could spend resources on something that's going to directly affect the youth
of society and sending them a message about what is right and what is wrong.
Um,
you know,
having grown up in a,
in a sporting household myself,
a three daughters,
which,
you know,
played sports growing up and I look at kind of what I went through and what my
daughters have gone through in the life's lessons that you learn in sports that
transcends sports and learn how to work under pressure,
how to work as a team,
how to individually succeed.
There's so many great lessons to be learned,
the health aspects of,
you know,
being healthy and working out.
All of a sudden you introduce into that equation,
number one,
breaking the rules,
breaking the rules.
And so there's,
you know,
the ethics to look at surrounding it.
And number two,
you know,
ultimately there can be risk and health consequences with using these things,
especially if you're young doing that.
So,
you know,
again,
going back to the message,
I think that it's sent to our kids and two parents with where I think society
was going back then with the pervasive use of drugs in sports,
I think was a positive one that's going to benefit people positively.
And I think it did.
It did have an impact.
How much does that guy way about how tall is he rather uh,
find the stats,
but yeah,
find a stats.
If he,
it depends.
I mean he could be like five,
seven and he'd still be 230 pounds built like that.
He's a fucking giant.
He's beautiful.
You like it?
Six feet tall,
two 20.
It's just an ape filled with fucking testosterone and fury.
God Damn,
that's an athlete.
That's about as strong an athlete is.
You get human vans there,
like,
you know,
great slave auction back in the day.
And this is just a stat that,
that I like to sum that grips my heart.
So that's why I want to say it now.
But,
um,
I mean,
I,
I think I looked it up right before I got in in here and it was around 11,000
people that a bullet took,
took out 11,000 people.
That's a ton.
It's a ton.
It's a brutal crisis.
But I just remember the uproar that,
that and the fear,
like the outcry that that happened publicly all over the United States and only
a couple people got it here and then,
and still,
that's terrible.
Um,
but whenever I compare that 11,000 people total in this Ebola crisis,
and then the stat for children,
and this is on water for his website and stuff and on ours and dude,
it's what I want to fight and let people know because there should be a real
public outcry and uproar that 5,000 kids,
5,000 kids under the age of five years old,
die every single day,
every single day because of dirty water,
because of water borne disease,
because of waterborne illness.
That's a legit stat from like UNICEF or one of those like legit places,
5,000,
5,000 a day.
It's like,
it fluctuates from like 4,700 or something to 5,000 a day.
And like for me,
man,
I've,
I've held two of those children.
You know,
I've,
I've dug the grave,
I've had blisters on my hands.
I've had a little dude named Andy bow his blood on my hands and like,
like Bro,
it's,
it,
it wrecks me.
And like that's why I'm so passionate about this thing.
And like
I come back and like I,
I get it a bolus terrible and we need to knock it out because it can take out so
many people,
but why?
Why are people not like,
why don't they have their eyes open?
Their ears open their heart open to hearing about 5,000 kids dying every day up
into the funeral of five other kids.
I've seen the grave of nine or 10 others besides that like,
and these are just among the pygmies.
I've been to the,
I've seen the funerals going on of the,
of their oppressors,
like the slave masters and the Mokpala than on pygmies that surround them.
Their kids are dying to dirty water and it's not,
I don't,
I don't mean to go crazy,
but no,
it's not crazy at all.
It's an that that statistic is crazy.
Yeah.
Most adorable,
nicest people in their world,
but yet look at that.
You said [inaudible].
Do you not like the word world?
I don't like world.
Is that how you say world?
How do you say it?
W O r a l d r before the,
oh,
it rolls off the tongue easier then go world world world world Bor old.
How do you say that world?
No,
no you don't say it like I said the world.
How'd he say we're old now?
That's the right way.
That's why I say no.
You say rural old.
How does he say at Jamie?
You say Debbie entourage.
It's the best thing in the world.
World world.
Okay,
keep saying it like that.
We're good.
You say world world world.
No,
he doesn't even say world world.
This is a world w.
R o.
L.
D.
That's what you say.
We're all old rod.
The best thing of the war,
all the old wound doesn't matter if you are do nothing bitch.
All you do is spend somebody else's money and try to look pretty like that's all
you do is you use stuff up,
you use up resources and you give nothing and so you're pretty much a drain on
society.
That's what I think they,
they don't think it that way.
They think what they are is something that all these men want to fuck low.
So in,
in working really hard to attain this,
this appearance and all these men want to fuck that.
Uh,
the what they are,
they've,
they've created capital.
They've created like a need for this.
I was just brought up to think that it wasn't your mission in life to be happy.
It was your mission in life to leave world better than how you found
it.
And by being a comeback,
right,
you're not going to do that.
So I go to Chicago and it's this Italian,
I'm not gonna use any real names because if people are still around,
so it was the one,
this thing instead of golf course,
and they say to me,
listen,
there's a priest here,
so can you,
so keep your act,
you know,
clean it.
Then I said,
okay,
fine.
So I got up on,
I do my little act to find,
thank you,
applause,
applause to sit down.
So this gangster guy gets up,
you know,
he goes,
oh,
welcome y'alls tutors.
You notice this place and wasn't going to say,
Oh shit,
I forgot.
I was going to say,
and what?
He said,
Shit.
The priest went
like this.
The guy goes,
well,
hey,
fuck,
you got your 10 grand on a fucking bag.
It just goes crazy and has got,
and then places just,
everybody's just just frozen with theater.
This guy,
he's just like crazy and the priest was like,
he's holding this bag with the 10 grand in it,
you know?
And then he sits now
sometimes I'm sitting there,
the guy come late,
Jay,
come in.
He goes,
let me ask you something.
You know,
stolen,
right?
I said,
why?
I don't know him but you rocky just come out.
This is 1976 I said,
I don't know him.
I mean,
I met him,
you know,
we ask them to do this dinner,
this benefit today.
And he said,
no.
He said No.
And I said,
well,
I mean maybe he was busy.
He scratch screaming at me.
I go,
you're right.
I'm sure be fine.
He goes up,
he goes up,
this is,
come on,
let's play some golf.
Honestly,
I don't really play golf.
Play golf on our golf carts and my point in this golf cart and we drive out to
about the 12th hole.
Let me get to the 12th hole.
And there are these kind of 50,
60 year old prostitutes,
topless with leopard skin print,
mini skirts,
handing out drinks.
It was like the craziest day of my life.
But this guy was like a true psycho criminal.
Get fucking
all the agents in there and being like speaking of lucrative,
I was winning with Ian Edwards this weekend.
I know Greg Fitzsimmons and Ian and I were a flying home and we were at the
terminal.
What we ran into this girl that,
uh,
Ian knew,
from the store and apparently she's a stripper.
And,
uh,
she,
we were sitting down having a coffee and she asked if she could sit with us.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
go ahead.
Sit with us.
And so she started talking about working at spearmint Rhino Strip in and this
and that.
And she worked this weekend and she was coming back and you know,
she was just talking to him,
you know,
everybody was cheap and this and that,
that and this.
And then she said she was working with this girl,
she's working with this girl and the girl.
Uh,
and I go,
I go,
what percentage of the girls that you work with are willing to have sex with
guys for money?
And she's like,
um,
there's quite a few.
She goes,
I worked with this one girl this weekend who was like,
how lucrative do you get?
And she goes,
what?
She goes,
how lucrative too you get.
Cause I get,
I be getting lucrative.
And,
and she goes,
what do you mean Luke?
And if she is,
I'll go,
I'll go back to a dude's hotel room for $1,000.
I'll get lucrative,
lucrative,
lucrative.
And this girl was married to a guy,
apparently that is not gay,
but is a dancer and dances for men.
And he does,
he's gay for pay.
Yeah,
he's gay.
It's like her husband is her husband.
He's like,
five guys were on a train on,
it's so fucking unacceptable,
dude.
Hey,
one night he doesn't have to work for the rest of the month.
Okay,
how's that?
How's your sleep?
Are you sleeping well?
Is Everything good
you out of your fucking mind?
He's lucrative.
He's real.
But he's that guy now that really is who he is.
He's like all the time,
24 hours.
You call him up in the middle of the night.
He's dice man.
Yeah.
He became that guy.
Yeah,
we uh,
I opened up for him for like two,
three years.
She really,
yeah,
he picked me out of the comedy story.
He came up to me and uh,
at first he goes,
um,
you know what you should do.
I said,
what?
When you go on stage,
put a shock
pants and then you'll be like the comedian who's just got a big cock
and this is like,
this is like my guy I looked up to
and he's telling me.
And then I actually went home that night.
Gone.
Should I do,
should I be cat gay,
uh,
fucking Connor exam?
Man.
I appreciate the fuck out of that guy.
That guy is doing.
He's getting the eyes on the sport.
Yeah,
he rob.
You're really pisses me off.
I feel like just tell him when he was in the fucking pressure,
but I wanted to rape him so bad.
Of course.
Wanting to kill him.
I want to back.
You know what car you can blow me like a cup of hot soup.
You son of a bitch but low me on like a cup of hot soup.
How's that work?
You blow on a cup of hot soup.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't,
but if he just blows you like that.
That's why it's confusing.
The vernacular is really odd.
Like blow jobs.
I don't understand where that
blow me.
Like a couple hot soup first time.
First Time.
There you go.
Yeah.
I've never heard that one before.
I've been around
the destination of the species,
the way that men and women interact with each other.
It's becoming poisoned by these people.
You grotesquely underestimate their influence.
If you write them off as a few mad crazies in student unions,
but they have gigantic purchase on,
on the media and therefore on politicians.
Well,
they certainly do when it comes to schools and schools
for women getting getting sexually assaulted on campus.
Listen though,
your president is parroting these myths from these of that.
Yes,
the Obama has repeated the,
um,
the sexual Harrison myth.
Obama has also repeated the wage gap myth.
You're dismissing these people are sort of powerless fringe crazies.
The president of the United States is repeating their talking points.
Don't tell me these people aren't influential.
It's nuts.
Well,
that's a different thing,
isn't it?
I mean,
when the president and the president is really just a guy who supposed to parrot
what everybody else sort of already believes anyway.
And if that's what the progressive democratic person,
I don't know if the Republican president would be any different,
there'll be a lot more Jesus talk.
What else would be different?
It will tell the truth.
Trump would tell the truth.
Do you really like Trump or is this a troll not accusing me of trolling?
What a horrible allegations.
I don't,
I don't know how we got from Beta comedian skull fucking passed out girls to
this,
but I'm trying men and men are different.
Uh,
that's the big picture and feminism is something that's created by men as a
false narrative.
Yeah.
Women have bought it hook,
line and sinker where there really should be at home protecting those very,
very valuable three years from 26 to 29 before their ervery's turned to sand or
something like that that you're being sarcastic because I'm listening to you
going,
yes,
well done.
Just keep on that feeling is understanding.
Go on and deeply at a light and go deeply yet letting go deeply in Ladd and go
10 times more deeply and that didn't go deeply in letting go.
I'm going to time it bladder and go deeply.
Yeah,
I had to go.
Yeah.
Have fully take him in letting go take command,
letting go
in,
go.
No hesitation.
I do this with the ovary and Matt as well and it feels wonderful.
Yeah.
I may have been whenever,
like they said the salmon and something else word like people are like the not
people.
One Guy,
I remember one guy like the shit on the fucking ground and was like,
break dancing in it.
Like trying to like,
I mean it sounds like I'm making it up.
I swear I'm not dude.
He was,
his goal was to like smear it around
as much as he could.
And this is in the room with you?
No,
no.
That was in the hallway.
In the hallway.
It was another dude.
It's breakdancing to his own shit.
I mean it looked like it was break dancing,
but he was like,
you took a shit.
And he's trying to smear it around as much as he could.
And so it just looked like it was break dancing.
Oh my God.
Because how is
when guys are telling a story,
it's hilarious.
And he's like,
she came up to me and started mad dogging me and I was like,
what the fuck you look in that I paid for all that shit.
And you didn't say none of that.
You just said,
I was like,
I had that look
on my face,
but I didn't say shit.
And if you don't question,
did you actually say that you're like,
no.
I was like,
I was,
I was thinking of like,
well one of the ass too.
You would have made it seem like you were just bad motherfucker in this story.
You didn't say shit.
And I was like,
fuck you for that shit.
He said that.
No,
no.
I thought it like I thought it.
Fuck you and all.
And where you came from,
bitch,
did you actually say it to him?
No.
What happened particularly in the academy and I was teaching philosophy in the
1980s and the chairman of my department asked me to teach a course in feminist
theory and I thought,
fine,
I'm a theorist,
I'm a feminism.
I sent away for the textbooks.
I was shocked by what came through the mail.
I spent the summer reading these books and as a,
as a philosophy professor of many years,
I thought there was a sacred commandment about college teaching.
Thou shalt teach both sides of the argument.
It never occurred to me.
It was my job as the teacher to take my views about the world.
And,
and,
and implanting them in the minds of my students.
I wanted to give them the,
the techniques to make their own decisions.
And you do that.
One way to do that is to give them the best that was thought and said on both
sides of a contentious issue.
Well,
these textbooks were not like that.
They were a series of mutually reinforcing readings and it was a conspiracy
theory about the patriarchy buttressed by inflated statistics.
So I,
after spending a summer reading this book,
I wrote a paper and and gave,
I went to the American Philosophical Association and presented it.
And I will tell you,
typically at the American Philosophical Association,
if you give a paper,
people are,
it's very combative,
Eh,
but then you go out for drinks.
Well,
we did not go out for drinks.
Uh,
I gave this paper.
Women mostly women in the audience were hissing and booing.
And I was excommunicated from a religion I didn't even know existed.
The church of feminism I was,
I was considered a,
that I'd committed an act of Harrison.
We're bringing him and I are talking about actually presents a,
a possible solution to what could have brought this planet out of the Ice Age.
Something on a grand cosmic scale.
And the other point I think I'd like to make is that we have to really to
understand our planet as a system,
we have to realize that it's part of a cosmic ecosystem and the cosmos has been
a much bigger player in what's been going on down here than has been a
previously.
Yeah.
Understood or appreciated.
And I think our ancestors probably did understand,
they did understand it.
They,
the,
the focus on the back then there was all that.
What were you wearing?
Well,
what did you think was going to happen?
I mean it was really,
uh,
it was,
yeah,
dude,
it
was,
I mean,
all of that,
that um,
uh,
frat boys shit,
all of that reputation was earned.
Just some of the sh dude,
I,
I've talked to guys like 10 years older than me and they tell me like half the
shit that they,
you know,
not have to ship a sizable chunk of some of their stories with the hazing and
shit they did with chicks.
It'd be like,
dude,
you guys would all be in fucking jail,
man.
A long time.
Yeah.
Like the 70s,
those guys that came of age in the 70s,
I remember how,
God,
I can't,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna name names.
One,
one night I'm riding in a car.
It was me and another comic and this other comic who was older and we would
drive and killing time.
We started telling pussy stories,
dude.
And this guy stories
every fucking other story.
Me and the other comic,
we'll look at each other like,
dude,
what the fuck?
I remember one of his stories ended with,
yeah,
there were a lot of no's that night.
It just like,
do,
we literally changed the subject,
Jesus Christ.
And he was sitting there laughing because like to him there wasn't,
that was what was done.
So,
you know,
uh,
I,
I don't any anybody that says from back then that that was done to them after
just listening to that guy talking about the 70s.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ with the 60s were like,
so I believe,
you know,
all of them.
It's,
dude,
it's a very strange,
like girls are joining and they're getting killed.
You know,
there's one,
one of the girls recently got beaten to death and another one got murdered.
It's like,
what is going on?
I thought it was closeted homosexuals at first I thought Alteryx tariffs where I
thought they were all just closeted homosexual gonna come after him.
Kreischer don't say my worrying about comp.
You've worried about comedy central,
but you know,
worried about saying that.
Yes.
That's hilarious.
Now you've been drawing Muhammad.
That's fine.
That's hilarious.
A lot of like,
like,
like homosexuality.
So kept down there like maybe they're just guys that are fucking,
no,
I don't think that's what it is.
Sitting in a cave.
Like,
Hey,
when I call blow,
you and the guys are like,
what?
And he's like,
I said,
blow up.
Let's go blow each other up.
Oh,
no,
I had Jeff Novitsky on the guy who busted him.
Um,
after he was on,
uh,
lance contacted me and a,
I had a conversation with him on the phone and he lands,
he may or may not do the podcast because he wants to tell his story.
By and large people can have the perspective that you have.
They can say,
look,
it looks to me like everybody did it.
So,
okay.
Uh,
then they can look to the line and they,
that's where they really start to not like it.
They say this guy lied to us repeatedly,
but of course you get,
you know,
my,
there's no defense to that.
But if I could,
if I could share any personal insight,
I mean,
once you lie,
once you just lying and keep listening as if I'm going to sit here,
you know,
this is 15 years ago and Joe,
you're a nice guy and you,
I mean,
if I was on this podcast,
I would have lied to your fucking face a million times.
Just so you know,
I would have just show you now,
just so you know,
that's not a surprise to you or anybody else,
but once you're in there,
it's not as if I'm going to go,
you know,
this,
this guy Joe seems like a really nice guy.
I think I'm going to be real.
I'm going to be honest with him.
Too much money.
There's no way you can't.
One second.
Yeah.
So I was,
I was stuck,
for lack of a better word in that,
uh,
in that does that lie or that deception?
But then the way that I took my competitive nature,
which served me well in training and in racing and took it into the real world,
took it into a press conference,
took it into a personal relationship,
took it into former teammates.
Uh,
my relationship with that,
what,
that's the part where people go,
okay,
fuck this guy forever.
Right.
I'm done.
And so,
um,
that,
you know,
you've got sort of three phases.
None of them are good,
but as it got further away,
um,
that,
you know,
lack of respect for others is the thing that totally fucked me.
And you know,
too,
that I would,
I would say to anybody that I understand and,
um,
I may be in their timeout forever.
Um,
I have,
uh,
and the only thing I will add that,
that,
that may sound like I'm trying to defend myself as I've,
I've tried to make amends with all those people.
[inaudible]
okay.